I'm so intrigued I've never done
anything like okay great
so so there is a mother energy that is
present so if your mom is not departed
it would be like a grandmother or an
aunt or someone that was like a mother
to you it could literally be any of this
because everyone died before my mom is
allowed okay you're very fortunate
because you have not lost a lot of
people here in the physical world yeah I
don't I don't know many people that have
passed away right so yeah I can I talk
about the dead that's departed
oh my dad did die oh I don't know him oh
oh yeah alright okay I was gonna ask you
about pie I like pie because I think
they showed me cherry pie and I'm like
okay what am I supposed to say with that
I don't have a cherry pie is my sister's
thing but she's one he probably is
trying to talk to well we don't know
each other but you have to understand
your dad could not take responsibility
for things in his life here in the
Nevada run his soul is stepping forward
and saying I know what you felt I know
what you went through and for that I am
sorry
so I've already forgiven so I'm good but
I'm not like mad at it if you can hear I
was like like that's not what this is
about okay you have to understand it's
where someone if they hurt us would
disappoint us if only if the soul has
learned the lesson you see things
differently they can come through and
say that so alright that's all my sister
for your dad to be able to come from
yeah Candace did lose someone yes
who are you she's my stylist oh hi nice
to meet you Oh oh my god like very first
thing you said his mother and I was
thinking my life but her mother recently
passed that's right yeah yeah were you
watching her breath in the end okay
so your mom just says just please tell
my daughter I know how much I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this